please welcome executive producer at
machinegames York Gustafson
[Applause]
hello everyone after liberating America
from the Nazi scum in Wolfenstein to the
new Colossus this year we take you back
to Europe with two new Wolfenstein games
first we are bringing Nazi killing into
virtual reality with with Wolfenstein
cyber pilot as a hacker working for the
French Resistance you will take control
of Nazi war machines and turn them
against their creators cyber pilot will
be available this July and it's playable
this week in our e3 booth
and if you haven't put Nazis in VR you
don't know what you are missing but as I
said we have two new Wolfenstein games
this summer we are going to be launching
Wolfenstein Youngblood
with a gameplay experience that is
bigger than any previous Wolfenstein
game you will have more weapons and
weapon upgrades than ever before more
ways to customize your playstyle and of
course even more evil Nazis to kill and
in Youngblood you can kill those Nazis
with a friend
yes Wolfenstein is going co-op young lot
is set in the 1980s two decades after
the new Colossus BJ blast which is
missing in nazi-occupied Paris and it's
up to his twin daughters yes and so to
track him down in Youngblood you can
still play by yourself or you can
partner with a pal to double up on
shooting stabbing and killing Nazis
check it out
[Music]
Paris Nazi country that's where Papa is
so that's where we're going we can find
him together
I may have an assignment suitable for
two knots Akira's such as yourselves
[Music]
the stewardesses
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wolfenstein young Lord releases on
PlayStation 4 Xbox one Nintendo switch
and PC on July 26
and if you can't wait stop by hurry free
booth to play this week thank you
[Applause]